Hi, Guardians.
Are you ready for one last ride?
Let's give the galaxy
something to remember us by.
Drax sit up. That’s what it’s here for. Drax!
It's called a sofa. It's not a bed.
We find it hard to believe
it doesn’t have multiple purposes
doesn't really matter, does it?
I'm sorry,
My friend is stupid. I'm hungry.
My sacred mission
is to create the perfect society.
I want you all to know that I am grateful
to fight beside my friends.
He didn't want to make things perfect.
He just hated things
the way they are
incinerate them.
We were always searching for a family
until we found each other.
Are you ready
for one last ride?
will fly away together
into the forever
and beautiful sky.
Whoever it
was that you were in love with,
it sounds more like her.
Her that’s ridiculous
Do not bring me into this
knock if off!
Just never notice how black your eyes were
They were replaced by my father
as a method of torture.
He he picked a pretty set.
Welcome back, everyone is Charlie.
There's a brand new Guardians
of the Galaxy three trailer
with a bunch of new footage
that will break it down.
If you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
I know there's a lot of questions
about who's going to be
on the new Guardians of the Galaxy team
after the movie because we know a couple
are going to leave permanently or Die
or RIP press F in the chat to pay respects
they beat.
He so will not stop talking about
how this is going to be his last time
as Drax ever.
So we know for sure he's going to not be
on the Guardians team in the future.
But you starting
with the brand new footage,
the Guardians of the Galaxy go inside
this creature's home inside Counter Earth.
So what are the creatures
at the High Evolutionary is upgraded
inside the MCU version of Counter Earth.
His main thing in the comics
that he's known for is creating human
animal hybrids,
which they find here in this planetoid.
Like,
Wait a minute, this looks just like Earth.
That's because it's counter Earth,
just like in the comics.
This whole thing, as he says in
the trailer,
is trying to create the perfect life him.
And he just feels like
humans aren't up to the task,
which is why he starts
creating these human animal hybrids.
Thus he creates beings like rocket,
even though they play this scene for
comedy like Drax, just trying to chill out
like it's a couch.
Why shouldn't they lie on it?
Everything is meant to look like
it's from your grandma's house.
That she hasn't changed
in the last 50 years.
Like the high Evolutionary
wants everything on counter Earth to look
quintessentially American, like old school
American.
There's a bunch of deep cuts
from the comics here too,
so we'll see if they wind up
using a version of man
Beast in the movie too,
because it's a huge part of Adam Warlock
origin story of how he wound up
getting the soul stone in his forehead.
Now he does have a gem in his forehead
in all the trailers,
but that's just tied to the way
that his power works in the MCU.
He doesn't have an infinity stone
in the MCU, but like you look on the walls
in the background, they have more human
looking people in stock photos.
Just everything is made
to look hilariously American.
There's more footage of Groot going
into what they're calling his Kaiju form.
They're calling him Kaiju Groot.
So like the thick, small version of Groot,
the Chad version of Groot
is going to be called Kaiju. Groot.
They also revealed that he can grow
wings in Fly, which is a brand new thing.
His powers in the comics
are kind of nebulous, though
he can pretty much do anything
that you could conceive of doing
with plants, trees, biological matter
or wood, just in general.
And if it wasn't clear
from the previous Guardians
of the Galaxy movies
or even the Thor movies
since he got stormbreaker like in Avengers
Infinity War, in Avengers Endgame,
the Wood that grows from Roots, Body
is super hard compared to normal trees.
That's part of the reason
why Stormbreaker is so strong.
Like the metal, The enchantments on it
that were created by the dwarves, by E3
are really strong, but also the handle
from Groot's Body makes it super strong.
The other funny thing about Stormbreaker,
if you didn't realize it too,
the wood is still alive like grew its body
there is still alive.
When he plants it in the ground.
It actually starts growing roots
during Thor, Love and Thunder.
I think that's also meant to be
a reference in the comics to his weapons
being alive
or having a consciousness to them
the way that the Infinity Stones
have a consciousness in are alive.
There you are. He
is just calling you.
We get a bunch more scenes of Adam Warlock
using his powers to pummel Nebula
into the ground, trying to destroy her.
She is super tough
because as she jokes about in the trailer
with Peter Quill and Gomorrah,
she's got all kinds of upgrades.
Ever notice how black your eyes were?
They were replaced by my father
as a method of torture.
Pete, you've picked a pretty set.
I explain the whole Marilyn Monroe twist
with her character
in my last big trailer video.
The whole idea
is that when they were trying
to figure out
what she sounded like in the first movie,
Karen Gillan couldn't quite get there.
So James Gunn told her to make her sound
like she thought that she was
Marilyn Monroe,
the really sultry whisper like quality
to her voice.
I thought you were the biggest
sadist in the galaxy.
That was when Daddy was paying my bells,
like a very stabby version of Marilyn
Monroe, which is why they reference
that during the What If series.
A lot of people remember that
she wore the blond wig and looked
a little bit more like Marilyn Monroe.
The whole thing with Adam
Warlock in the movie is
this body is coursing with that annual ax.
Battery energy which is baked into
his body are in the sovereign
create those batteries.
They're a big part of the plot.
During the Guardians of the Galaxy
two movie,
it looks like some of their energy
is based on quantum energy, too.
Like they're just meant
to be incredibly powerful batteries.
They basically just bake
that technology into his body
and that's how he creates
those energy source.
Like to see Drax
grab one and try to stop him.
That seems like an extension
of one of his powers.
Like he kind of creates
the MCU version of a lightsaber.
He can give it off and blast.
You see it coursing all over his body.
And it's also probably how he can fly.
Like he uses it
the way Iron Man would use or technology,
except he doesn't wear a special suit
to generate the energy.
It just comes from his body.
It it probably has something to do
with the gym in his forehead.
Just like a lot of his powers
in the comics are tied to the gym
in his forehead, which in the comics
are usually the soldier.
The other big thing about Adam Warlock
is that it
usually gave him the name Adam
during the second Guardians
of the Galaxy Post-Credits scene,
but nobody has called him Warlock yet.
That'll probably wind up happening
in this movie
early theory
is that he'll just do something crazy
with his powers, and one of the characters
will call him a warlock because of that.
Usually in the comics though,
he started out being called Warlock
and then eventually later
one of the beings on Counter Earth
that he helped save when he was getting
the soldier from the high evolutionary
called him Adam.
But in that case it was meant to be more
of a biblical reference because the story
that was taking place in
was more of a reference to Bible stories.
I don't think they're taking
the more religious aspects
of his character in the MCU.
Like this is meant to be a little bit
of a different vibe with the character,
but James gets it.
They're playing him in this movie
the same way they played
vision in Avengers Age of Ultron,
like a born yesterday kind of vibe, where
he totally does not understand
what's going on, but he's meant to be nigh
invincible, like he has crazy powers,
but just has no concept
of what's going on,
no real understanding of good and evil.
And that will just continue in the future.
That'll be a big part of his arc.
In the same way that Vision pondered
morality during Avengers Age of Ultron.
Here I'm variably naive.
Well, I was born yesterday.
We get more flashback scenes
with the high evolutionary.
It actually seems like we see a couple
of different versions of the character,
like one of them has hair,
and then in the later footage you see him
with his skin all pulled back
like he's been upgraded even more.
That's actually right out of the comics.
The whole idea with the character
is that he started out
as a regular human, Herbert Wyndham,
and then slowly upgraded himself in.
The reason why he wears a mask
is because he messed up his face
so bad while he was upgrading himself.
So all the footage of him
in this tank here
looks like him getting ready
to upgrade Rocket in the past.
Like this is a flashback of Rocket's
origin story.
You also see the high evolutionary
looking like he hasn't upgraded himself
quite as much either,
so that in present day,
when they see him on counter
Earth, he looks way different because
he's given himself way more powers.
That's
also another thing about the character.
He's meant to be super powerful,
but his powers are also kind of nebulous.
He continually upgrades himself
to give himself more powers
and make himself more powerful.
He's even been able to fight
beings like Galactus, like that's
how powerful he gets.
They don't show you a ton of his powers
in the trailers.
We only see him use telekinesis
and it looks like he can also fly.
But he has way more powers than that.
Just in terms of the new team members,
like who's going to be on the new roster
after this movie?
We already know Cragen
Probably going to survive
and become a main team member,
but he's already kind of on the team,
like he's been on the team for a while.
Peter Quill will probably continue
as Star-Lord Groot in his new Kaiju form.
Cosmo The Space
Dog may be the new version of Gomora.
I don't think she's going to die,
but she might not continue with a team.
Like she might go off on her own.
Nebula will continue, like
we'll see more nebula stuff in the future.
We already know Drax is not continuing,
but Adam
Warlock was a big member of the team
in the Annihilation Conquest storyline
and that's where they had these versions
of the uniforms
that you see in this trailer.
So early theory
he winds up joining the team.
Nova was a member of the team
in the comics
and they have been talking about
introducing the character in the MCU.
There was a deleted scene in Avengers
Infinity War
that introduced the character.
I've already gotten a bunch of videos
about that.
Right now
they're talking about doing him in either
a special presentation or a Disney
Plus series, not a movie.
So we'll see where they wind up
introducing the character.
There's Beta Ray Bill.
He was also on the team
for a while in the comics
and there have been a bunch of beta ray
deleted scenes already in the movies.
There are a couple longshot characters
too, but people have been asking me
because they're introducing X-Men
to the MCU, especially after Secret Wars.
So like Kitty Pryde
was a big part of the team in the comics.
She even got married to Star-Lord
for a little while, but I'm not expecting
her to join the team.
Captain
Marvel could wind up joining the team,
but they want to use the character in so
many other different Skrull based stories.
Nick Fury stuff.
I'm not expecting her to join the team
either.
Moon Dragon Quasar in Agent Venom.
We're also members of the team
at different periods,
but like I don't expect Agent Venom,
for instance, to come into the MCU
because we already have the Eddie
Brock version of Venom,
and I don't think it's going to change
any time soon.
But let me know in the comments
which new Guardians
of the Galaxy team members
do you want to see from the movies?
There's a bunch of big stuff
that just came out,
so I'll try to do videos for everything
as fast as possible.
Make sure you enable alerts
from my channel so you don't miss that.
They also just started releasing
The Mandalorian Season three episodes.
Click here for my full episode one video
and click here for my Episode
two Trailer video.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one.